on voit dans sa voiture pierre aperçoit
des gyrophares en action à quelques
centaines de mètres un policier a arrêté
son véhicule pour effectuer une
intervention la rue n'a qu'une seule
voix et la voiture de police en occupe
au moins la moitié
pierre rul environ au 50 km heure la
limite permise sur cette rue il se
demande s'il doit passer à côté du
policier ou et il décide de dépasser le
policier en ralentissant à environ 30
kilomètres heure sur pays tout juste
après le premier policier se trouve un
deuxième policiers interceptent pierre
il lui remet une contravention parce
qu'il a enfreint l'article du code de la
sécurité routière portant sur le
corridor de sécurité comme il avait très
peu d espace pierre est passé près dû
prier ici
son confrère estime que ce n'était pas
sécuritaire de rouler si près du but à
30 km heure pierre aurait dû ou ralentir
davantage ou s'arrêter ou encore si
aucun véhicule n'arrivait en sens
inverse passer sur l'autre voie le fin
mot de l'histoire
vous devez préserver la sécurité des
policiers pompiers ambulanciers ou
contrôleurs routiers